[Music]
black hair is the most amazing versatile
hair that there is the mix of my mom and
a mix of my dad and that's what i love
the most about my hair i love my hair i
feel
that my hair is a part of me
the black hair care market is a
multi-billion dollar industry
and in america although black people
make up a third of the non-white
population they account for almost 90
percent of the spending in the ethnic
hair market
but the stats don't reveal the full
story
throughout history textured hair has
been the target of great oppression
affecting black women's wealth and even
their health so what is the hidden cost
of having black hair
[Music]
many black people have experienced some
form of prejudice because of their hair
every time you go to school with a new
hairstyle i would go feeling great but
then you get all the kids wanting to
touch it and put their sticky icky
fingers in your hair and just became
like tiresome a co-worker came into my
cubicle
and proceeded to
pet me
and
it was probably the most uncomfortable
experience i've ever had at
in a work setting
a survey by the perception institute
asked black and white women to score
their attitude towards different hair
types out of five with five being the
most positive
it found that on average white women
regarded smooth hair as more beautiful
attractive and professional than
textured hair
this attitude is something tamara jokes
ball the economist's u.s policy
correspondent knows all too well
it has been considered unacceptable for
black women to be able to present their
hair in the way that it grows out of
their head and often that means having
to do a lot of things to move their hair
closer to caucasian standards so that
might involve processing their hair with
chemicals so it becomes straight that
might involve dyeing their hair and
that's really time consuming and really
expensive but the stigma against black
hair
runs deeper than just black versus white
there's a stigma also within the black
community the same survey found that
black women also believed textured hair
was perceived as less beautiful
attractive and professional from very
early you realize that your hair is
either good or bad and often it's
compared to people close to you like
your mother or your sister for
african-american women when their hair
is closer to caucasian beauty standards
they're often considered to have good
hair
the concept of good hair began hundreds
of years ago
in 14th 15th century africa the hair was
really really important in
proclaiming one's identity
you really wore a hairstyle that told
the world who you were what family you
belong to what tribe you belong to the
more elaborate your hairstyle meant the
more status that you had
but the transatlantic slave traders
shaped the heads of their captives
stripping them of their identity
for many enslaved people in the new
world their hair became a means of
survival having good hair meant that
your hair was kind of good enough to
allow you to be seen as human instead of
animalistic
the hair was one of the few things that
could be manipulated so if you could
make your hair look less african and
make it look more european then you
might actually not have your child
ripped out of your arms you may not be
beaten as badly you may not be given
such back-breaking work that will kill
you before your 30th birthday so
literally from birth
black mothers would try to
straighten their children's hair
straighten their own hair
just to see if they would be seen with a
little bit of humanity
even after slavery was abolished the
pressures of black women to have more
eurocentric hair continued
if a black person wanted to find a job
working
with or amongst white people then they
were going to continue to try to copy
their styles so that they could be
you know easily assimilated into social
society
but with the rise of the black power
movement of the 1960s and 70s natural
textured hair became a political
statement
to keep black hair looking like white
hair
it's like it's extra work it's just your
time it's extra money and so there was
this faction of black people during the
civil rights movement who said you know
what i'm not even going to do this
anymore
but it didn't last with a shift towards
more conservative values in the reagan
era fashion reverted back to more
processed styles like the jerry curl
fast forward to 2021 and black women
still feel pressure to radically alter
their hair
a study in 2019 found that
african-american women were 80 more
likely to feel they had to change their
natural hairstyle to fit in at work
many people spend a lot of time and
money on their professional appearance
on top of all the other things black
women have this added layer of worrying
about whether or not their hair blends
in with what white society deems
acceptable whether or not we need to
straighten our hair to be appropriate
for work or whether we can wear braids
or whether we can wear our hair in our
natural state
for braids if i'm doing it myself it
could take anywhere between
eight hours to
24 hours i have to give myself pep talks
and i have to really like
build up the courage of getting my hair
time
the days that i am doing a
aloe vera pre-poo and then i go in and
then i'll do a henna treatment or i'll
do uh onion juice treatment they have to
sit on my hair for like two hours so
this becomes like a whole day of hair
it's not just time consuming but also
expensive
a survey by mintel found that almost
half of black women in america use five
or more hair care products at home
[Music]
i've definitely come down a bit over the
years a lot
because i could i could say thousands
i've spent thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars we've been led to
believe as black women that black hair
is complicated you need like 500
different products you need to do a
seven step like wash day routine but in
reality it's not the black hair business
in total is estimated to be anywhere
from four to nine billion dollars
depending on who you ask i mean you have
stylists you have the hair weed business
is enormous it's a multi-billion dollar
industry the product business the
shampoos the conditioners the creams all
of that but often these products are
difficult to source from mainstream
shops
seventy percent of british women of
color feel the high street doesn't cater
for them perhaps not helped by the fact
that many of the biggest global hair
care brands do not have a black woman on
their board
it's a world away from the early years
of the black hair care industry when it
was dominated by entrepreneurs like
madame cj walker
but then decades later you started to
see that money go towards more
white-owned or asian-owned businesses
we're starting to see a bit of a turn
now with women being able to sell their
products online
but we're still seeing this disconnect
between who's spending all the money and
who's actually getting the money
rachel chumasi coulson and joyce lynn
mate are trying to disrupt the hair care
market in their office in london they've
created a brand to take on the hair
giants
the problem when it comes to afro and
curly hair is that you can often end up
with people that don't really understand
how black hair works but will make
products just because it's lucrative so
many of these products are not being
trialled on real people with real afro
hair as they're being made they're being
tested on chemically cold straight hair
so that means most of the products out
there don't work that well but it
doesn't matter because the customers
will keep buying it and if they buy the
first thing and it doesn't work they'll
buy the next thing then the next thing
and then the next thing frustrated by
the lack of products on offer rachel and
joycelyn started their own hair care
company
i was suffering from traction alopecia
which is hair breakage i just made a
hair oil that i used myself gave extra
to rachel it was like this is great
let's start a business together
we made 50 hair oils at the time sold
them in a trade show and some of the
people who had bought the oil emailed us
saying they wanted more and that's when
we realized that there are more people
like us who are looking for good
products for afro repair
in 2021 they raised 1.2 million dollars
in seed funding and now sell in 27
different countries
their popularity has been helped by a
growing awareness of perhaps the most
serious side effect of processing
textured hair
the cost to women's health
when i was perming my hair when i was a
pre-teen and a teenager
you kind of knew that it probably wasn't
safe it didn't smell very good
we had scabbing and burning so you knew
it probably wasn't good but when i
started doing research it was so much
worse than i realized
a study in 2019 by the national
institutes of health found that african
american women who regularly used
chemical hair straighteners were around
30 percent more likely to get breast
cancer than white women
and it's not just occasional treatments
like relaxes or perms that are toxic but
also products used on a daily basis
epidemiologist tamara james todd
researches the health effects of
chemicals used in textured hair care
products you'll note on the label
oftentimes the word fragrance well
fragrance is synonymous with hundreds of
different types of chemicals and one of
the things that's holding that fragrance
in there is a type of chemical called a
phthalate
and phthalates have been found to be
associated with adverse health outcomes
when these chemicals get inside of our
bodies they can really disrupt those
normal processes so they can impact
reproductive health cardiovascular
health and so on
dr james todd's research found that half
of the products being marketed to black
women contained hormone-disrupting
chemicals and those were just the ones
disclosed on the label
in america it's not a requirement to
safety test ingredients in personal care
products before they are used
the european union bans 1 300 chemicals
from cosmetics but america bans just 11.
here in the united states we could do a
better job by regulating
the usage of these types of chemicals so
that we could hopefully reduce risk
a growing awareness of these health
risks has contributed to the rise of the
natural hair movement
the natural hair movement that we are in
the midst of right now
is
truly revolutionary because it is a
movement
founded on changing the notions of
beauty for black women when somebody
says wait a minute your natural hair the
way it grows out of your head is
appropriate for the workplace it is
gorgeous you should love it
that is revolutionary
between 2016 and 2018 sales of at home
relaxes dropped by almost a quarter as
more women embrace their natural hair
[Music]
alongside this raised awareness of
textured hair have come much needed
changes in policy
some states and cities in america have
passed the crown act banning hair
discrimination
and there's a chance it may soon become
federal law
in britain hair care companies are now
being encouraged to support natural
hairstyles
and since 2021 all training hairstylists
have to learn how to cut textured hair
but there is still much more that can be
done
while the natural hair movement is
empowering
it still has a long way to go before we
are able to really truly be free in
terms of our hair choices there's a lot
involved still even with my natural hair
to get it to the texture and the shape
and the definition that is considered
acceptable for me to go to work when we
can get to a place where black women can
also have a messy hair don't care or
whatever hair do and walk out the door
and be okay and be considered
professional then we would have made a
lot of progress
it's important for all women to feel
that they can arrive to the world the
way that they are naturally and that
when they do so they're in full force
they're beautiful they're confident
they're professional they're everything
they need to be and more
you can read my piece on black hair by
clicking on the link thank you for
watching and please don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]